alors maintenant je suis un ordi je
m'adonne à la botanique maintenant
depuis quelques dizaines d'années
l'idée c'est d'essayer de marie le plus
possible le vécu de nos arbres d'intérêt
avec l'existence des gens qu'ils ont
conservé
en tout cas pas et ce qui est important
c'est comme ça que les gens vont
développer l'amour l'amour des uns
[Musique]
mais simon ni sur le domaine c'est
henric du ster joly de lotbinière
c'est un personnage hautement historique
parce que d'abord il a fait beaucoup
pour que diffuser l'information sur la
sylviculture sur le domaine ici bien au
fait des plantations des différents
designs et patiemment 10 des plantations
de noyers noirs
noyer noir c'est un arbre d'abord et
avant tout américain il y en a dans une
petite partie du sud du canada on en a
tous réussi à l'étang du jeune dans les
provinces maritimes mais vraiment des
toutes petites stations
[Musique]
ma démarche se distingue de celle des
américains qui vous au
reste toujours un arbre remarquable
comme le plus volumineux moi j'ai
développé une série de toutes sortes de
critères qui entourent justement
l'aspect historique pourquoi ils sont
nés pourquoi ils ont été observés etc
les armes c'est pas des meubles un m'a
donné les planches et le plafond lee
potts quand on a longtemps vu l'arbre
comme ce mois je ne vois comme du
matériel vivant
[Musique]
noyer noir c'est un homme qui a une
allure exotiques c'est un arbre d'abord
tu deviens volumineux et qui est plus
coloré à luton que notre noyer cendré
qui pousse naturellement ici
[Musique]
c'est un peu beaucoup de retard les
corses ressemble un peu à celle de
fresnes avec une allure textures et à
feuillage léger les folioles temps pour
un paquet de larmes jaune au pied de
votre sujet remarquable qu'une grande
histoire à raconter
[Musique]